je reçois aujourd'hui le photographe
helmut newton pour la sortie de work son
nouveau livre d'imagés pour le fameux
sumô bonsoir et newton avait 80 ans
vous les faites pas du tout c'est
incroyable non mais vraiment je sais pas
ce que vous prenez beaucoup de comprimés
à beaucoup de contres et même en tous
les cas ça nous a tous les cas bien en
forme donc ce qui veut dire que j'étais
né à berlin en 1920 votre famille grande
bourgeoisie juive avec chauffeur bonne
et cetera dans votre père était
industriels
et puis alors ils vous prennent ils
disaient qu'on lui disiez que voulait
faire de la photographie vous prédisait
un avenir un avenir catastrophique
absolument dit si on ne fait pas la
photographie tu fais c'est attendant le
week-end ouais tu fais quelque chose de
sérieux tu deviens monsieur sérieux dans
des affaires mais alors vous avez eu
c'est vrai une vocation très précoce
j'ai acheté ma première appareil photo à
l'âge de 12 ans avec de l'argent de
poche comme ça vous le payez vous même
et votre première photo on la voulait
fait aussi à 12 ans alors le premier
film y avait huit images dans le film
mais il n'avait qu'une qui étaient
bonnes j'ai pensé à la j'espère une gêne
me croire donc c'est une photo de la
tour de la radio de berlin la foule
tourner qui est exposé d'ailleurs très
très bizarrement votre première photo et
a été exposé à paris dans une galerie
oui alors à 16 ans là vous découvrez la
vraie fan vrai travail faisait
travailler chez yves à la fameuse avenue
de berlin qui s'appelle le
kurfurstendamm ai alors parlé nous dit
va pas c'est une femme
très très belle d'abord très célèbre qui
avait cet atelier de photos ce parcours
en france un peu oui moi j'étais un
apprenti à l'époque on a fait un
apprentissage on n'était pas à
l'assistant et c'était 2 ans où j'ai
appris le métier de te plus bas de le
faire le développe le neveu de valeur
ces terrains c'est une femme formidable
que j'ai adoré alors à celle dont moi
j'ai eu 16 ans elle était célèbre toutes
les célébrités qui passait tout ça c'est
une belle une belle s'était lui même
alors elle est morte à auschwitz
d'ailleurs la peau est claire quand on
sait que j'ai commencé à travailler dans
les années disons 30
à berlin on retrouve des choses de
cinéma impressionniste allemand mut
renard langue tout ça à 0,6 et lumière
en noir et blanc comme ça très très
stricte
on voit bien d'où ça vient je vous le
dis toujours tu peux pas nier tapas et
wii 2 ou tu viens oui oui cette fois
elle sait mettre sans observation alors
se mêle à cette façon de faire des
images se met le bagne évidemment les
routines qui est très importante chez
vous vous avez votre premier baiser
c'est avec la fille de la concierge
dabo par an je sais tout et quelques
années plus tard c'est après 13 années
50 mais ça explique un peu le
cheminement d'helmut newton quelques
années plus tard vous découvrez histoire
d'eau qui était interdite à la fin des
années 50
évidemment vous découvrez ça ça vous ça
vous fait six blessés les bouquinistes
donc c'est vrai quand on sait ça
l'impressionnisme allemand histoire
d'eau on voit un peu effectivement
comment sont nées toutes ces images qui
vous ont rendu mondialement célèbre
depuis alors en 38 vous fuyez les
persécutions nazies et vous quitter
l'allemagne partait à singapour des 18
ans de dollars en poche il l'a
effectivement vous trouvez un job dans
un journal à singapour qui s'appelle le
strike times cette lettre formidable
singapour 1938 une ambiance à la
somerset maugham nouri extraordinaire
vous avez tué un homme
c'était dangereux parce que je termine
facilement dans command fille dans un
des quatre murs historiques
oui c'était dangereux réseau j'étais un
peu dans la vie chaud c'était très
amusant de voir ses dires et sert que
après deux semaines il faisant virer un
dit je ne suis pas en porter ils sont vu
que les résultats que j'ai amené à la
rédaction était pas très points 13 1%
dans la rue après voilà deux semaines
alors vous fait virer du journal de
singapour donc le strike times vous
partez en australie pendant pendant et
là vous faites votre service militaire
cinq ans j'étais dans l'armée
australienne et c'est comme ça je suis
devenu australien dans l'ead accord et
c'est comme ça que vous avez appris à
conduire des poids lourds est à vendre
à 22 ans pendant cette date ces
premières photos publiées c'était juste
juste après la guerre très je crois
cette [ __ ] des semaines après la guerre
c'était dans une magazine ça plaisait
aux spurs
enfin notre les jeunes profs qui
n'existe plus il y avait un effet de la
couverture c'était en couleurs ma
couleur à la main ah oui c'était avant
ektachrome d'afrique
st et moi j'étais tellement emballé a
excité je suis coup rude en kiosque mais
pour voir si c'est très ouvert pour
regarder ouais ça représente quoi
comment s était urgent de photos de mode
un groupe notamment d'une dame qui porte
n 1 et chats ces premières photos
publiées donc à 22 ans est là pour vous
retourner à la vie civile ou fait des
photos de mariage fait que vous pouvez
faire pour pour vivre et en 1948 vous
rencontrez jude rhône donc qui devenu
votre femme est une actrice de théâtre
en fête qui faisait modèle pour des
photographes pour un peu d'argent de
poche vous l'épousé et vous êtes
toujours mariée oui ça fait un moment ça
fait assez rare surtout vous en plus
avec le nombre de jolies femmes que vous
avez le nom de tentation vous avez eue
je trouve les actrices sont plus un
autre sens quand même il mais maintenant
je trouve ça que les modèles wi une
actrice est quelque chose
c'est assez bizarre mais difficile mais
dans cette a été trop tenté finalement
ce sont des gosses que vous leur faites
chauffer il ya mais pas seulement des
gens pour vous qui le dites vous les
hommes john brawn du newtown deviendra
disponible 170 quand elle se mettra à
faire de la photo elle a pris une
importance considérable dans votre vie
mais après ça on ne chante propre
travail de portrait ou ici alors la
réussite doit pas faire tout votre vie
mais là je voulais montrer comment la
génèse de votre note vous voudrez vous
commencez à être très célèbre convoque
lance une édition australienne et vous
tu fait votre première photo de mode à
l'époque et c'est vrai que bon d'un coup
tout le monde se rend compte qu'il ya
quelque chose
alors après vous partez allons au milieu
des années 50 et puis sous presse était
pas long et vous débarquez à paris et 56
a le coup de foudre affaire d'amour
ensuite parce qu'on avec paris qui a
duré très longtemps qui a duré jusqu'aux
80 de 56 qu'elle a rôdé au début c'était
pas la joie parce que vous travaillez
toujours là je la joie mais c'était pas
la joie ou se faire qu il n est pas ce
qu il faut savoir manger du bien sûr les
postillons a frôlé un franc le litre ce
délicieux
il faut dire que va vous payer 200
francs la photo c'est dire qu'à l'époque
c'était considéré que travailler pour
vox très très bien et ce n'est pas la
peine en plus de seuil et de payer les
photographes non ça coûte l argent à
travailler pour voilà alors voilà bon
vous lancez votre votre style évidemment
qu'on a vu convoi comprenait et vous dit
à l'époque c'était plus facile parce que
les rédactrices en chef de mode était
follement avant garde et oui une grande
différence que c'est un m à l'époque on
a fait des choses qui passera plus
jamais dans un journal comme ça dans un
journal de mainstream
ouais impôts si vous aviez fait un truc
c'est pas dans quelques jours a b c est
pour ça qu elle s'appelait alors y
adhèrent à huy il avait dans vos billets
175 donc il y avait un mannequin deux
hommes un petit chien il ya des gens qui
sont demandés si la manne qui n'avait
pas eu des relations avec le chien ce
qui fait qu'il ya eu des désabonnements
des protestations
enfin voilà quoi c'est le puritanisme
américain ça vous choque beaucoup non
vous savez j'ai l'habitude mais non mais
c'est pas trés ça ça fait facilite pas
le travail mais il ya une question de
on ne peut pas dire ça faire ce qu'on
veut il faut être là quand même
alors voilà qui alors après veillez à
vous bien sûr il ya eu ben youssef donne
gourdin gourdins et vous avez donc
révolutionner et recréer la photo de
mode
tous ensemble quoi louis entre brodin et
moi on a fait beaucoup de choses et
évoque à tous les deux pendant des
années il faut regarder c'est une grande
époque
alors on va terminer sur cette phrase
helmut newton vous dit certains
travaillent l'ofrou l'acier moi ma
matière première c'est la viande humaine
oui mais c'est la vire en tête qu est ce
parce que j'ai dit il ya la fille way
qui vendent qui vend de la photo pour
trouver c'est que marche et vous allez
trouver plupart oui c'est quelquefois je
me des fois c'est qu'on fait ce que vous
faites là les filles regard des défis
tout nu avec des minerves bah oui ça
c'était bien et votre femme
ouais je vous dis quoi dans ces cas la
lgv ou non contraire mais moi j'ai eu
peur quand j'ai vu la première fois que
j'ai dit à john tu sais je crois je suis
allé trop loin j'ai dit non tu sur le
bon chemin quand il faut continuer et
enfin j'ai continué j'aurai toute une
série comme ça qu'on est en hiver quand
il a fait crash oui il s'est sûrement
inspiré un peu d'helmut newton et
l'egypte à la qui a écrit un livre qui
t'aiment peuvent heureusement qui
m'admirent beaucoup ému ni tirer qui
influencent beaucoup de ces claire de ce
que je fais et je suis très fier de ça
la goutte et merci nous on est très
fiers de vous avoir reçu en tout les
grâce à ce qu on a beaucoup de risques
on a beaucoup de respect précis et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou